At the World Economic Forum on Latin America,
we set up the Davos Debates video booth
and invite presidents, dignitaries
and business leaders in attendance
to stop by and respond via video
to your questions and ideas
about the region’s most pressing challenges.
So, what are the challenges and opportunities
for Latin America in the next 10 years?
Pose your idea or question in video or text
and submit it at YouTube.com/Davos.
You can vote on your favourite
submissions from others too.
We'll put the top-voted submissions to
the leaders in Cartagena, Colombia
when they come to the Davos Debates booth,
giving you direct access to some of the most
powerful and influential people in the world.
Go to YouTube.com/Davos today
to join the conversation.